this is what hard feels like I was way
back in my day like you a party promoter
but I was in a fraternity and this was
my first semester being president we do
this huge party to like launch the new
class and the next morning they all wake
up and they're all hungover vomit in the
corner or whatever and we're like great
clean it up and they feel terrible and
they're like what the [__] this is what
I signed up for right two weeks of this
they get together they wanted me to meet
them because they want to meet on their
Turf I just asked them a couple
questions I was like who here before
pledging started was like I want to be a
part of this house me okay who here
thought it would be hard they raised
their hands I'm like guys this is what
hard feels like and then all of a sudden
it's like they got permission to feel
shitty and by getting permission to feel
shitty they stop feeling a shitty